Tom palace arrow covering the NFL and
Tom before we get started height and
weight please
listed weight on my driver's license and
height 5 foot 11 1 55 in reality I find
3/4 did Kyler Murray ruin the story now
that he's five-ten if isn't isn't the
story better if he's he's under 510 to
me the bigger story was that his hands
measured in at nine and a half inches
now as we've seen in the past with the
likes of Brandon Allen Cooper rush their
various YouTube videos you can watch and
perhaps gain a quarter interest so but
he was all the way up at nine and a half
inches that's Matt Ryan territory it's
not quite the Russell Wilson drew Brees
ten and a quarter myth but it's not bad
alright how much of a buzz did Kyler
Murray's measurements bring out there in
Indianapolis I got a bunch of texts from
Scouts today saying good for him that he
was able to pack on pounds you know when
Scouts were going through the October
calimary was winning 189 pounds which
obviously is very white he's he's an
outlier in every different way you know
this is a player who based upon the
measurements on paper once you see ten
years ago you would have been talking
about him in grass meetings but you
would have been talking about him as a
slot receiver it seems like some of
those hard fast rules I don't want to
say have gone out the window but teams
seem more willing to accept the fact
that maybe some of the body types and
things that are outliers you know may
not be completely prohibitive to having
success in the NFL yeah be like Antoine
Randall L who was a quarterback in
Indiana and then of course became that
slot receiver for the Steelers I was
also wondering this that you know we
measure everybody's words with what they
say certainly at the combine and you had
the Cardinals GM Steve chyme where he
said you know Josh Rosen's Mike's you
know our quarterback for now and
everybody jumped on the for now what do
you think is gonna happen with the
Cardinals cuz it feels like that I don't
know if it was a slip but I'm hoping
it's a little more calculated than that
from the Cardinals perspective it was
calculated I can tell you having spoken
people with the Cardinals and just kind
of asked around here they are enjoying
the fact that for the next 56 days I
think it is they're going to be the
center of the universe and all the
speculation is going to be on the number
one pick it is interesting that after
the season there were strong support
issued for Josh Rosen and now you begin
to get these little hints about well
right now and all those other things
could the Cardinals want to potentially
if somebody trade up get a draft haul
move back and take Kyler Murray could
they just think that they can put the
pick up for bid in general they got a
lot of work to do on their roster but
everything for them through this
offseason from the hiring Eclipse
Kingsbury opt-out hasn't really seemed
to be about please come to Glendale
please get in the stadium please buy
season tickets drafting the Heisman
Trophy winner who is you know an
exciting player with regardless of his
measurements would kind of fit that
pattern but there's also a lot of
skepticism from people who know that
team that on draft day they're actually
going to do it and take calimary number
one yeah I think if you're all in on
Kliff Kingsbury then be all in on Kyler
Murray because Josh Rosen might turn out
to be a good quarterback you're not
coming out to see Josh Rosen you'll come
out and see Kyler Murray and the
Cardinals were not relevant last year
nobody cared you know he Cleveland
became relevant because of Baker
Mayfield so not that that's why you take
somebody but in this situation Kyler
Murray I would have no problem
whatsoever taking him and you know
trying to find a trade partner for Josh
Rosen that's a large part of why it
makes sense even setting aside the
football you're right it has been about
creating excitements I mean trying again
trying to get people in the seats trying
to sell corporate sponsorships and all
that what's fascinating is good
Kingsbury and his opening press
conference and Steve time has said that
since talking about how Josh Rosen and
fit in that scheme well Josh Rosen could
not be more of a polar opposite as a
quarterback from Tyler Burnett Josh
Rosen is a pocket passer he's going to
stand in there read the defense and
throw with Tyler Murray you're looking
at something along the lines of what you
know likely people the Seahawks did with
Russell Wilson which is bootlegs get up
outside the pocket get him on the move
not just utilize the athletic ability
but make sure that he can be able to
see downfield you know here you don't
have to go to a full shotgun scheme all
the time are you gonna be able to play
him some under center there's a lot of
things you'd have to figure out but I
mean shoot there was no precedent to
take a six-foot quarterback last year at
number one oh man I worked out pretty
well with Baker Mayfield and now Cuyler
Murray okay let's just lower the bar two
years you will have a [ __ ] six pass
record number one yeah people's heads
exploded last year when Baker Mayfield
it's six feet you know can he play and I
was like do you watch him play like we
get caught up in the measurables and
then you talk yourself out of drafting
somebody because you're going well you
can't we look at all the teams the
example I use yesterday tom is all the
people who talked themselves out of
drafting Steph Curry
or Steve Nash because they didn't think
that they could hold up to the rigors of
the NBA and my point is always who's
guarding them they may not be able to
guard somebody but who's guarding them
and if you have an advantage in that
situation then you take that guy and you
had to Hall of Famers that you know
teams passed on because they didn't
measure up to what size you had to be
Cleveland did the same thing they said
you know what the heck with it we think
he can play either Kyler Murray can or
can't play I don't care how tall he is
Lima this Dan with all the the new
metrics and all the different ways you
can test guys in this environment they
still run the 40-yard dash
they still do this shuttle is over the
three cone and a big part of that is
because you're talking about comps it's
all about being able to compare okay
who is this guy like how did that
project forward that's how Scouts look
at they want to be looking at guys 20
years ago and figuring out okay you know
in the past what has happened when
you've had some of similar types of
numbers I mean I always think back to
one thing that Bill Parcells told his
Scouts for years and years which is you
were trying to make a case for somebody
in the draft room who is a little bit of
an outlier he'd go name one name one guy
who you're saying is like this guy if he
couldn't do it it was gonna be a really
tough sell that's you can't name one
like Kyler Murray but you couldn't name
one like Baker Mayfield either of course
you have guys like Drew Brees and and
Russell Wilson but those are there's a
rare rare talents and Baker showed in
year one that certainly the game's not
too big
but this isn't about drew brees as much
as it is russell wilson in my opinion
because breeze is a pocket quarterback
he's not a scrambler he's he's not fast
but Russell Wilson it feels like changed
the optics of what a quarterback has to
be or can be and I think he opened the
door more than Drew Brees did what do
you think Owen Russell Wilson Russell
Wilson was also a third-round pick and
there were teams I can tell you that at
Baker Mayfield in the third round other
draft boards last year I just didn't
believe that it was going to be able to
translate not not entirely because he
couldn't play but just where is the
value I mean yeah that John Dorsey
taking Baker Mayfield number one
certainly opens some new windows here in
terms of okay this guy may not fit but
you can't entirely also be looking at
what are other teams gonna do where
others he's gonna have them on the board
do you think you can get the quarterback
for the next 10 15 years take them you
know it's in my opinion you know and
just talking to people through the years
it's if you are convinced that this guy
is a franchise quarterback if you take
him at number one or number 12 or number
60 doesn't go get that guy if you're
wrong of course it's gonna boo meringue
on you just as hard regardless of where
you [ __ ] - Tom Palace Aero the NFL
Network you can follow the NFL Network
reporter on his Twitter and it's at Tom
palace Aero NFL Network providing live
coverage the 2019 NFL Scouting Combine
March 1st through the 4th the market for
Nick Foles it's open but it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of places here it's
not a [ __ ] that's not a big I don't
know I'm wondering no what the market
dad that's it Jacksonville that is that
is the market that's that's part of the
reason they're a huge part of the reason
that the Eagles weren't able to find a
trade partner as soon as the Broncos
made their trade for Joe Flacco does
that made it virtually impossible for
the the Eagles to create any kind of a
trade market and the Jaguars I can tell
you've never showed interest in making a
trade for Nick Foles now it's a
completely different conversation now
you're into simply signing him as a free
agent if you look at some of the other
teams that we don't know and there's not
many of them who the starting
quarterback is going to be with
in Redskins they've not ruled out a
l'instant playing at some point in 2019
Alex Smith has not ruled out playing at
some point in 2019 and they are still
paying a lot of money for Alex Smith so
there's some reasons to think that if
they bring in somebody else will be a
lower level veteran they may draft
somebody the Miami Dolphins is the other
one well the Dolphins are going to go
young they're they're going to be sort
of a rebuilding type of an operation do
you want to be paying a quarterback 20
million a year when you're in that spot
probably not so the Jaguars just make so
much sense we can oversimplify things at
times I don't think this is one of those
cases he's worked with the offensive
coordinator John Dee Filippo when both
were in Philadelphia they've got a
defense that's already made they are a
run first offense they can gear things
around holes it it makes a ton of sense
unless somebody else emerges here and
really makes a play which will also make
the interesting to see how much money
Falls is able to get if in fact it's
really only one team if we're gonna
slice up Steve Kimes words the Cardinals
to him yesterday then I have to do the
same to mike Mayock the new Raiders GM
where he did say derek carr is a
franchise quarterback he didn't say our
franchise quarterback do you think the
raiders are all in on derek carr moving
forward I don't think the Raiders are
all in on anything moving except for
John Gurdon and probably mike Mayock
they're there they've got three
first-round draft picks they've got
holes all over the place in terms of
their roster they traded away Khalil
Mack and Amari Cooper you know in a span
of a couple of months last year and
they've still got a year at least until
they end up playing in Las Vegas
everything's been for them focused
forward on 2020 getting to Vegas ready
to roll then what to do you know his
Derek Carr the guy I know the judge
Rudin has spoken highly of his working
relationship with car that he does
believe in him but you know talking to
people around the league here in
Indianapolis I certainly don't get the
sense that anybody is really anything
out including them potentially taking a
quarterback in this trap one other thing
and I know that you wrote about this
reported on this I'll go back to Cuyler
Murray and the role that his dad could
play in all of this is he one of those
helicopter parents hovering here and
could that be an issue
well then you had Cuyler on your show I
believe at one point you were asking dad
dive in for a comment within that
interview and I can tell you credit to
the show a lot of NFL people were
watching that too a lot of NFL people
were watching all the interviews that
Kyler Murray did during Super Bowl week
they were awkward to say the least your
dad Tom they certainly got the sense
that this was not a kid who is in
control of his career and that is not
just simply from those interviews it's
also from digging into what happened
when he transferred from Texas A&M
digging into the way that you know
baseball has kind of been an influence
here and the fact that early December
Scott Boras is proclaiming publicly that
calibre is completely committed to the
A's meanwhile two months before that
scouts have been getting asked by people
at Oklahoma saying hey Tyler's dad's
been calling about about potential draft
projections for the NFL what do you
think of a guy it's not something that
is you know something that's going to
rule out Tyler Murray or a huge knock on
the kid who by all accounts gets a very
nice kid or introverted quiet laid-back
that a lot of quarterbacks but teams are
absolutely going to want to spend time
with Kevin Murray they're not entirely
comfortable just with baseball being in
the back pocket if if Tyler goes to a
team he doesn't want to or if he's not
starting right away could baseball
potentially be an influence I did I
reached out to Kevin Orie before I wrote
about this and talked about it you know
he says that we're advising Tyler but
he's the one making his decisions he's
all-in on football it's you know
something that teams that are
potentially drafting calimary are just
gonna want to examine thoroughly you
know because you've got to ultimately
develop the confidence that we're not
going to be wasting a pick here Thank
You Thom you're doing a great job have
fun there in Indianapolis
that's Tom Palace arrow NFL Network
reporter yeah that's just one of those
interviews that's always gonna be
cringe-worthy Oh a Dan Patrick show
brought to you by Mercedes AMG they
sponsored the mancave just go to the Dan
Patrick show lap if you missed any of
our interviews including the one with
Kyler Murray at the Super Bowl Mercedes
AMG driving performer for more Dan
Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]